معنى من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه لواء فايز الدويري مرحبا بك
سيد فايز امم لنبدا مباشره بما اعلنته
القوات الروسيه القوات الاوكرانيه السيطره
على سوليدار شرقي اوكرانيا ما اهميه هذه
المنطقه لكلى الطرفين في حال احكام
السيطره عليها
يعني اذا ما حقق الحديث الروسي عن السيطره
رغم النفل الاوكراني ماذا ستقدم اولا
العقبه امام القوات الروسيه منذ شهر قبل
اسبوعين دخلوا الى اطرافها الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
واخرجوا ودفعوا مسافات متباينه عنها اذا
ما سقطت سوليدر ما هي العلاقه من منظور
عسكري وما هو طبيعه التاثير على اخره فخمه
تتعرض للهجوم من الشرق ومن الجنوب
واستعسع عليهم ان يقوموا بمهاجمتها من
الجانب الغربي الان اذا ما تحققت السيطره
على سوليدر يصبح الان الجبهه الاضعف لباخ
لان الدفاع مصمم اصلا على شكل ثلاث ارباع
الدائره من الشرق جنوب والغرب فيما من
الشمال لم يتم اختبارا هذه الخطه الدفاعيه
هل تم تبني لخطئه الدفاع الدائري ام اتفاق
الدفاع على شكل قاطع واسع من ثلاثه
اتجاهات الان اذا ما كانت هذه المدينه غير
محزنه وغير مجهزه للقتال باتجاه الشمال
فالقوات الاوكرانيه سيتم قطع طرق امدادها
سيتم محاصره سيتم مهاجمتها تجبر على
القتال بما يطلق عليه في العلم العسكري
الجبهه المعكوس وهذه اضعف انواع الدفاع
وبالتالي قد اذا ما تحقق سقوط سولدر ستسهل
السيطره
كل هذه التطورات الميدانيه تحدث بينما
كانت روسي اعلنت هدنه لمده 36 ساعه كيف
تقييم ما حدث خلال هذه الهدنه ورده الفعل
الاوكرانيه والدوليه عليها
اوكرانيا رفضا ذلك بالمطلق واستمرت
العمليات الاوكرانيه وهي تتمثل بالقصف
المدفعي والصاروقي في منطقه بخمه سوليدر
في
جبروتيا في غيرها والعمليات العسكريه
المتحركه في كوبيانس وفي سباته وفكر يمينه
بقيت مستمره بالجانب الاخر الجانب الروسي
اعلن انه سيرد بما ان الجانب الاوكراني لم
يتبنى وقفه اطلاق النار واستمر في القتال
فامر بديه ان القتال مستمر اما الان ما هي
الدوافع خلف هذا همم تم الحديث كثيرا
والاتحاد الاوروبي او الحلف الاطلسي ولا
غير ذلك قالوا بانها استغلال للوقت لاعاده
تهيئه القوات من منظور عسكري قد لا اتفق
مع هذا التوجه لماذا لان الفتره قصيره جدا
والجانب الاوكراني بقي على اسراره على رف
اذا دعيني اقول لن تسمح ببناء القوه ولكن
انا كراي شخص قلت واقول ان وراءها ثلاثه
اسباب اولا همم اظهار اظهار قيمه ودور
الكنيسه واهميه الاحتفال في عيد الميلاد
حسب التقويم الشرقي للشعبين لانه ال- ال-
الغالبي العظمى تقريبا ارثوذكس الامر
الاخر كان هناك طلب من الرئيس همم التركي
قبل 24 ساعه من الاعلان عن الهدنه وتحدث
عن ولو وقف اطلاق نار من جانب واحد الامر
الثالث هي رساله لل- همم للجانب الاوروبي
والعمريكي بان هذه قد تكون
محاوله جريئه من اجل توظيفها للبنات عليها
للوصول الى مفاوضات العمليه
بدنا لم تحصل همم على ارض الواقع لم تنافذ
على ارض الواقع لا بل كان هناك حديث عن
همم محاوله تسيطر على سوليدار ثم الاعلان
الروسي عن السيطره على هذه المنطقه فضلا
عن القصف المتبادلات لكن اللافت هنا ان
محاولات التقدم والسيطره على المناطق
استمرت على الرغم من اجواء المناخ والتي
كان يقدر الخبراء انها ستكون عائقا امام
التقدم وان اي تقدم الاستراتيجي لن يحصل
قبل بدايه فصل الربيع ما الذي ساعد في هذه
الجبهه تحديدا على محاوله التقدم فعلا
يا سيدي اولا يعني احنا
الجميع معظم الخبراء تحدثوا عن تاثير
الطقس وانا كان راي انه يبطئ يبطئ
العمليات العسكريه ولا يوقف
هناك تحدي من اكثر من بعد اولا حركه
الاليات والقدره على او المهاره في
استخدام السلاح نعم تتاثر ولكن لا يلغي
القدره على تنفيذ العمليه
تزداد العقبه والصعوبات لكن يمكن تنفيذ
العمليه يعني يشير الى نقطه نقطه
اذا عدنا من شهر ابر الماضي
والحديث يرتفع ويخبو حول السلدار وباخمد
ولكن طاق مثلي لانها اكبر ولانها تمثل همم
وهذا الجنوبيه للقوات الروسيه غلطت اهميه
على سوليدار لكن في الفترات التي كان يشتد
القتال في فرق كان اكثر من 10 هجمات نفذت
على سندار وفشلت وبالتالي الشتاء لن يحول
دون تنفيه عمليات ولكنه يضفي صعوبات او
يضع عقيل اكبر وصعوبات اكثر امام القوات
المتحركه
شكرا لك الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
اللواء فائز الدويري حدثتنا من عمان